Chapter 11 is a lot about relationships. We don't go too much into relationships
in this class because we tend to be a little bit more focused on the medical side.
But let's go ahead and take a little bit of look.
So one of the interesting things is what is a friendship?
They talk a little bit about some of the themes of friendships,
but one of the interesting definitions of a friendship that I've always read
is that it has to be voluntary between two people.
And I always love the voluntary part.
And the truth is just because I think I'm friends with someone
doesn't mean that I'm actually friends with them.
I have to have some sort of relationship with them.
And it has to be of a mutual aspect.
So assuming that we have friendships going,
and that we are mutual and that we both desire this friendship,
then the question sort of comes is how do friendships build?
So as we talk about the building of friendships,
there is what we call the ABCVE of building a friendship.
So the acquaintanceship stage is basically just when you get to know somebody.
So you can look around your class and you can say,
hey, there's somebody who looks interesting.
They're going into the same program as me.
And I don't know, they seem funny.
I like funny people.
And then you might at that point decide to sit next to them in the next class.
And you start talking about some things and you discover that you both like science fiction
and you both hate cowboy movies.
You know, you both have parents who have been divorced when you were teens.
But basically you're building up.
You're beginning to know each other.
This is called the social exchange at this point.
You exchange something with them, they exchange something with you.
And it's a very careful tip for TAT going back and forth.
If you give them too much, they run away.
If you give them too little, they don't bother to come back.
So during the building up phases where we begin to decide if we want to keep this as a continuous friendship.
And then of course we have the continuous friendship.
Things keep going and we keep doing things together that are interesting.
Now eventually most of our relationships, most of our friendships will go into deterioration stage.
Now the question is why do friendships begin to deteriorate?
Now it isn't usually from a big fight.
That is generally not the reason that most of us begin to have friendships that deteriorate.
It happens to do more with a change in your life, a change in their life, different aspects that happen.
And that you're just not connecting quite like you did before.
So one of the interesting things about people and friendships is actually a distance.
So here I am, I'm in this little spot right here.
I'm not very good at drawing, but we already know that.
So the question is, is if I was to draw a circle around this person,
how far do we tend to travel to sort of maintain a close friendship that may even turn into a different type of relationship?
And you'll hear people give all kinds of different times.
But if I had to get my little car and drive, the question is how far would I drive?
And we've got a pretty good answer for that.
The distance between here, where you are, and the end of that circle is right around 30 minutes.
So 60 minutes across, 30 minutes one way.
When it gets to be much more than 30 minutes one way, we do find that most relationships begin to step back.
They begin to deteriorate, or they become Facebook friends.
And think about it, we live here in Brevard County, and we have a lot of good friends perhaps.
But if that friend was to move to Orlando, you quite often begin to find that over a period of time that friendship begins to deteriorate.
It's not quite as close as it was.
It may be that at first you see each other, you know, a couple of times a month, and then it goes down to a month, and then it's every couple of months.
And then sometimes when there's a big event going on, and we go to Orlando, or they decide to come over to the beach kind of thing, becomes more of a special occasion that you get to see them.
So that's sort of the deterioration stage.
And the ending stage is when we sort of lose that connectiveness.
Now, ending doesn't mean that we never see them again. Quite often I like to say the Facebook people are an ending phase.
You know, you have them on Facebook, but the truth is you really don't communicate with them.
It's more about just, you know, seeing what happens to them and following up on them.
But you don't really have that connection, you don't really have that mutual friendship anymore.
What you have is more of a, I'm curious what's going on with their lives.
Unfortunately, in relationships, there are also bad relationships, in this case, violent relationships.
And so what I want to talk a little bit about is this concept of the battered women's syndrome.
Now, battered women's syndrome is a true syndrome.
Basically, this is when a woman feels that she has an inability to get out of a relationship.
And the only way that she can get out of that relationship is to quite often do something violent or something very finale, final.
It is not a question that they are women who are in battered women's syndrome who have killed their spouses.
And why this happens is that, as you see through this sort of system here, is that after a while the woman is completely separated, she's no longer with family or friends.
And she may begin to feel like this is the only way that she's going to be able to get back to normal, or the only way she may become safe.
Now, one of the steps in this particular slide that I stole from somebody,
and unfortunately, I don't know who I stole from otherwise I would give them credit, but I'm telling you now, I lifted this one, is that the battered woman who has children will have another step in there.
If she feels that that battery may begin to affect her children, meaning is that she feels the better or will go after the children, she will perhaps look for a more finale way to end this.
When we're in class, I often ask, do you think that the battered woman is going to be somebody who is from a poor family, from a medium-income family, or from a wealthy family?
And quite often, I have people pick basically the poor family.
Most people don't pick the medium family, and a few people will pick the wealthy woman.
Well, they are right, the medium-income family, not as much happens there.
In part, quite often in the medium-wealth family, the woman has her own job, and so financially, she can afford to leave the relationship.
So then you would say, well, it's the poor family because she can't afford to leave the relationship.
And it is true she may stay in a battered relationship for a longer time, but battered women's syndrome often involves killing your spouse, you might want to say.
And the poor woman, quite often, is to afraid to kill the spouse because that could be the loss of her income.
Not only that, but in the poorer sections of society, there is more help for a woman who may be getting battered.
There are more shelters, there are more systems in place.
The problem with the wealthy women, is that quite often the woman who is in this is a woman who is not wealthy to start with.
She comes from a lower to middle-income family, and one of the things he does is he separates her.
He pulls her away from everybody she knows, and eventually, maybe she gets to go live in the Hamptons or something like this.
But if you think about this, there are not a whole lot of battered women areas in the Hamptons, and there's not a whole lot of houses together.
Not only that, but he becomes very controlling, and it says there at the very bottom of the partner is controlling and abusive.
If he's the breadwinner, which generally he would be, he controls the credit cards.
She probably doesn't get any cash, they may not even use cash.
So anything she goes to do, he knows about.
They probably have expensive cars, which means there's GPS tracking systems on it.
So even if she decides she wants to run away, he's going to know where she's at.
If she says to him I'm going to leave you because you're so mean blah blah blah he might threaten her with and who's going to believe you?
The sheriff is my friend and the lawyer blah blah blah and then the the the and basically
Convincer that she's not going to win. She says I'm gonna take the kids with me. He's like you're not gonna take the kids and blah blah blah
So what happens is she becomes this trapped feeling? The other thing is is that people quite often don't recognize that she is being battered
So she is in the Hamptons and she breaks her arm. He hits her she falls on the stairs
She breaks her arm. They quite often have a congee your doctor who comes to the house and brings the x-ray equipment and all that and sets her arms
So that doctor has a record of that
But in the next season they go to Aspen and when they're in Aspen
She breaks her ribs and guess who she sees a different doctor and a different
Person and then maybe they go to New York and there she gets some sort of a contusion again a different doctor
What happens is that quite often there's no medical record that follows them?
Unlike the poor woman who tends to be going back to the same hospital at the time and after a while
The authorities might even or the medical staff begin to recognize the signs of this in this particular situation
The woman is being treated by different people at different places. So quite often this battery goes for a very long time before it's recognized
Not only that but wealthier men if they tend to batter their wives
They don't tend to do it in the face so much. You may see risks that are bruised
But he needs quite often that good face
To be the face of his party or to do whatever he's doing
Not only that but he often has what we call the spies. Now. They don't start out as spies. They're the housekeeper. They're the
long guy and because
He has had a relationship with these people and he generally seems very nice and friendly and he says to him, you know
I think my wife maybe
She may be sipping a little on the alcohol in the middle of the afternoon
If you see her doing something could you give me a call if she suddenly seems to be leaving or packing her bags or doing something
You just let me know. I think I might need to get some help from my wife
And unknowingly these people can actually begin to help him spy on what the wife is doing
So this sort of violent relationship this battered woman syndrome can lead to ultimately the wife killing the husband
One of the things that is interesting in this is that we call the battered woman syndrome
But we may be beginning to see this as not just a woman syndrome in part
That's because in these relationships between men and women quite often is the man who has the greater power
But what about our relationships with homosexuality now that we have homosexual marriage as a
Standards you might want to say
Are we going to see the same type of battery happening there you see in the past?
two men who may be in love and
Wanted to create a partnership quite often still had two separate spaces
And so one partner could go back to their own apartment and quite often did go back to their own apartment
So that the more powerful member of the relationship
Perhaps wouldn't be known for their relationship. You have to think about
People like Liberace and a lot of our movie stars in the past
They had people who with them all the time, but they didn't live with them so much
So one of the interesting things that sociologists and psychologists are going to be studying is whether or not this syndrome would occur with
Any type of couple where you have one person having a lot more power and authority. You might want to say over the other person
So far it does look like it doesn't really have to just be women. It's more about power
We know that basically almost all of this type of violent relationship is more about having power and control over somebody
When we talk about abuse we did talk about the fact that there is sort of a difference between abuse and neglect so abuse tends to be
purposeful where a view where neglect is not always purposeful it could be but neglect could also be
I just don't have enough money to buy my son a sweater because it's cold outside
I just don't have enough money to buy fruits and vegetables because I'm poor right now
I've lost my housing so we have to live in the car. That isn't always purposeful. Where's abuse is?
The types of abuse often are caused for different reasons as you see in this particular
chart as
People who are going into the medical fields or the psychological fields
They're going to have a lot of training on how to spot abuse and how to report that abuse
so here
I just like to introduce this and then move on and allow you to have the specialty classes on this subject as you want or as you
desire but it really does come down quite often to somebody on the outside helping the
Person report their abuse or even spotting it
Sometimes the person is being abused doesn't even realize that they're being abused you might want to say after all
it's how they grew up maybe they had an abuse of family in the first place and they're used to dad dealing at mom and hitting and
you know dad yelling at them and
Taking out the belt and belting them across their butt when they were little and so how is this any different?
This is what life is is how it's supposed to be
So what does make a successful marriage then well first of all we do know that the older the couple is when they get married
The more likely they're going to be successful
People who marry in their early 20s have a much stronger chance of having their marriage not succeed and
When it says here the couples have to have a similar interest in values this becomes really interesting is that we tend to say oh
Opposites attract well, that's not exactly true
What we're talking about here is when you talk about opposites you're talking about more
Surface things like I like sci-fi and you like I
Know action adventure and so I introduce you to sci-fi and you introduce me to action adventure
And then we discover that they're sci-fi that's action adventure, you know, I like
Country music you like pop music and we kind of introduce each other to those things. That's what we're talking about
We're talking about is your basic values and when we talk about your basic values if you're an optimist
It's very hard to be with a pessimist if you are a
Oh, let's see a conservative it's very hard to be with a very liberal person if you tend to be very close-minded and very
traditional it's gonna be very hard for you to be even attracted to somebody who may be much more modern and
Expressive in their ways so what we really find is that we have to look at people tend to have the same values
That's one reason why a lot of times people meet people at their local churches
You might want to say because the church quite often attracts people have similar values in the first
place, so you find that person has the similar values and now you're looking for people who have somewhat the same interests and
What we mean by the same interest here is that you there has to be something that you enjoy doing together
if you don't find anything you enjoy doing together then very quickly you're going to become bored or
Not particularly enjoy that person and it's one thing to say on a date
Well, I'll go try something because I've never you know really tried it before let's say opera
And this other person really loves opera and you really hate it and all they do is talk about opera opera
You know for a little while you can kind of pretend to like opera
But after a little while you're not going to like opera and that relationship will begin to fall apart
So it is important that we find some interests together
However, those interests could lead us to different aspects of it. So you like horses and he likes radios, okay?
Well, we can maybe combine that together
so
With this coming then one of the things that we have to say is why do married couples stay happy and
One of the big things that I always like to talk about in this particular section is this particular thing right here
The stress-addidation model
Basically satisfaction is a function of a couple's abilities to deal with stress and that is so key if we can't deal with stress
Then we find that we're going to find it very hard to stay together
Stress is what tends to cause things to fall apart. So if we have the ability to come together to deal with that stress
Then we're going to find that this marriage is going to the last and it's gonna be happy. It is one reason why when children
die in a
Relationship so there's a couple as a kid it dies
Quite often that couple will fall apart. They can't deal with the stress together. They they can't
Lean upon each other that the stress of the death of the child is what pulls them apart eventually
Of course where there's a mom and dad
We're probably going to form a family as we get a little bit older now there are two very common families
There's the nuclear family mom dad
Most common in Western societies, but the extended family which consists of children and grandparents and all kinds of other things living together
That's actually much more common around the world and if we look at which is the most common type of family in the world
It is going to be the extended family now in America mom dad and the two kids
Yeah, that's pretty common, but we're a new country and we haven't had to build up over time
We are beginning to see some more extended family living especially more in the cities and as more people have come over from other
Areas who are used to extended family living if we go around the world quite often we have family compounds
It's not uncommon to have you know a large
Couple of acres and you have three or four houses or in a city where a family owns what you'd consider be an apartment
Building but they have four or five residents, and it's all the same family living in there. So extended families are much more common
Being that we live here in a tourist area. We also have to understand that a lot of our tourists come as extended families
So you see these large groups of people coming over and they may all live together
That can be very challenging when we're at restaurants or if we're in ER's
Because they are used to being able to do everything together
Familyism is the other one that we have to take a look at
Familyism is pretty simple. Basically the family is more important than the individual
This can be seen quite often in
Countries or cultures where they really support one member of the family
So let's say one member of the family turns out to be really smart
so the rest of the family will actually work really hard to chip in so that person can spend their time studying and
Chip into that person could go to the better school and chip into that person can go to the debates or whatever it is
They need to do and we'll chip in to get that person to tutor so they can get good grades on the SAT
And we'll work together to get that person into college and to help that person live through college and get out of college
and do whatever they need to do to get set up because
What happens is that that for the family that tends to be very good because that person is then now going to help the rest of the family
Move up and so that person may send money to the rest of the family or help the other members of the family do things
They may work in their office
They find another kid who's good and that family members going to help the help each other
so the family
Takes over rather than the individual like a family business where you have a daughter and a son who begin to learn that family business
Everybody works together because the family business is more important than the individual family
This is very common when we talk about communities where extended family living is more than norm
For most people once they get married one of the next things that they look forward to is having babies or starting their own families
We know that in today's Western societies couples are having fewer and fewer children in part
That's because of economics and you would think that oh, it's because it's more expensive actually. It's the opposite
It's the fact that they are working and so less children is
Easier to take care of but also the fact that basically our children are living when we had high death rates of children
You would have multiple children in hopes of getting a few to adulthood
But today we pretty much figure our children are going to make it to adulthood. We don't sit there and think as some people
You used to have to worry about is that 30 to 40 to 50% of their children weren't going to make it to adulthood
So 50% of my children aren't going to make it to adulthood
I'm gonna have six kids with the hope that three make it to adulthood today
We actually have most kids make it to adulthood. We have very few children who are dying young
So we can push back having kids until we're a little older. We're a little bit more settled. We have a little bit more money
But what's also interesting is that men who become fathers as they get older
Tend to spend more time with their children and caring for their children
Now in part the reason for this is that younger men are still trying to make their way in the world
They're still working on their status and their relationships and where they're going to be or basically where they're going to wind up in life
As we get more toward middle age
We may have made our location. We're kind of where we're going to be or we've reached to that pinnacle
We also may have reached to an economic pinnacle where we can afford extra care or good quality day care
and so we have that ability to go ahead and have that child and
Spend some time with a child because we are able to have people who can help take care of that child
I don't have to work perhaps as many hours or it can work from home because I'm in a more professional job
men who are even older who have children quite often have them and
Really want to be very heavily involved in the raising of their children the older they get
They may not have had any children or they had a child when they were very young and
While they love that child and they raise that child
They just didn't have the time to be involved with them because they were still
Creating their life and they were still trying to create where they're at
And so they have another child later in life because they want to be heavily involved
So it is interesting with fathers as age comes their time caring for that children increases
With
Another group of families we have is things such as step family now the step family is
Something that's pretty common these days
What's interesting is is that as we have the next generation coming the Z generation is what they're sort of calling it these days
You quite often find that they're not using the terminology like stepdad or step mom
To them everybody is part of the family everybody is a member of the family and as
Somebody once told me I don't have a family tree. I have a family bush. You don't hear them referring to their
Blended families as having my step brother or my half brother. They're just my brother
And the other kind of group we have to think about are foster families now foster to adopt families are basically an
individual who has decided that they will foster a child who is in need of a family if
Things work well, they will be able to perhaps adopt the child
but quite often in foster families they never get to adopt the child because the child is either not up for adoption meaning that the
parents have never given up their custodial rights or
There are other circumstances that come in. This is not a law class
but these are still true families and
They still have true feelings for each other our biggest problem with this is maintaining that bond
They have with their foster children because the children may come in for three or four years and then be moved to another family
It's kind of interesting how that's done
With adopted families probably one of the biggest fears is that they will not be able to bond with their child
They hear these stories of kids who never bond with their parents and there is truth
There is a psychological conditioning in which young children may not bond with their parents
But for most adopted children they are well bonded with their parents now
We did talk early on when we talked about babies we have to remember that there is a sort of a critical time period when kids
Begin to develop a bond with an adult. So remember they don't come out of the womb automatically bonded to people
Basically, you got food. I like you
But we do know somewhere around that eight-month period until about 18 months
They're beginning to develop a bond with somebody and we call a strange awareness and quite often children who may be adopted right at that point
That can be rather difficult for them because they finally bonded to someone and now they don't get to see that person
And so they adopted family who has gotten this child who's just crying and crying and crying
Thanks. Oh, they're never gonna bond with the child. They will bond with the child. The child will bond with them
They may have to give some time for that to occur because the child is grieving for the bond that they have finally made and a little afraid
and a family that is
Becoming a more established today is our gay and lesbian families now
We do know there are a lot of states that have passed laws that were against gays and lesbians marrying
In fact, there are still lots of laws on the book that will not allow a gay or a lesbian family to adopt a child
They can foster a child, but they can't adopt a child
They could foster the child for ten years, but never be allowed to adopt the child
But this is one of our newer type of families. You might want to say
When are the interesting things that has aroused because we now have
Better data you might want to say on these types of families
Is that people thought that the environment that the children grew up with would affect whether or not they too were gay or lesbian?
And what we found is that children who are raised in a gay or lesbian household
Are not more likely to become gay or lesbian themselves
And what they are more likely to do is be accepting of other gay or lesbian people
But there's just as much heterosexual and homosexuality
In children in a gay or lesbian household as there are in heterosexual households
In fact, this thought that if there is not a father around that a boy will become a homosexual
It's sort of disproven with the amount of single mother homes that we have and a lot of single mother homes
Who do not have a father figure at all in there because as we know women who are more middle-aged
They are not probably going to get remarried. It's much harder for a middle-aged woman to become
remarried and so she may be raising her children on her own
So there is no strong father figure if it was true that you know not having a man around makes you
Homosexual then we would have a lot of gay little girls and boys running around
What we do know is that this is going to be much more likely to be a biological
We know that there's actually a gene that's associated with homosexuality
If you don't have that gene, there's probably never going to be homosexual
But the interesting thing is is just because you have the gene doesn't mean that you're going to be homosexual
So there's probably gonna be two sort of parts to it
It's one reason why homosexuality probably also runs through families because the gene would be passed on
There is some look at looking at homosexual
gay men's brains that they tend to be a little bit more feminine in nature
One of the hypothesis and remember hypothesis is an educated guest. So this may get disproven as you listen to this
Is that perhaps there's something that happens in the testosterone wash when a child is in vitro. Remember we all start female and then
What happens is a testosterone wash comes through and turns the fetus from female to male
Well, what if that wash doesn't come through quite right?
What if the wash is a little behind or a little early or not enough or whatever and we also have that recessive gay
Gene in us then is that what may be causing a certain percentage of the population to?
Understand that they are homosexuals rather than heterosexuals a very complicated topic and one we're not going to go in too much further than that
Except for that laws now do exist that allow gay marriage and allow
Homosexual couples as well as heterosexual couples to have families
Unfortunately where there are marriages there are also divorces. So basically in the United States
There's a 50/50 chance that a couple is going to get divorced however the earlier that they marry meaning as you see here between
2024 the higher the percentage that their marriage is not going to last all the way to the end is
This the same percentage around the world. No, you have to remember in some countries. It's still illegal to divorce in some countries
Where they may be super religious they may never really officially divorce, but they go on to move with other people. It's still a type of divorce
Why people tend to get divorced is a whole lot of
Issues, but what is interesting is is that if we look at the top reasons for women and the top reasons for men the first three
are basically the same
Communication problems and happiness and compatibility. That's why we said that in the beginning for marriage to really work is that you have to be compatible
you have to have some sort of
Relationship based on common values and some common interests without that
We're probably not going to go ahead and really find that we're going to have a long-term marriage
It's going to be hard to keep up sort of you might want to say pleasantries if we really truly disagree at something
That's really down into our core
When we talk about the effects of divorce the one I always like is one of the most common things that will make a divorce not
Be successful is what we call the divorce hangover
Basically this obsession that people have with their ex and keeping up with what they're doing and seeing what they're doing and being jealous of what they do
Basically, they get stuck in the past. They get stuck with
What was?
This does not matter if you're male or female both do it equally
You can hear men talk about I can't believe my ex wife is doing this this this and this and you can hear women
Go I can't believe he did this this you have made two separate lives
And it's time to basically have separate lives
And you know what one of you might make it financially better than the other one might get more recognition than the other
But the thing is is that you're not together anymore and you have to learn to make that separate life
But if we become stuck with being obsessed with our ex that is truly going to find that we have an unsuccessful divorce
So this is the end of this lecture
Again, it's normally if you have any questions, please email me at Ramona be at Kaiser University dot edu and I will see you soon